thank you
[Music]
I'm gonna show you a picture of a dude
and just tell me based on how he looks
what this guy did to end up in jail [__]
I could already tell his [__]
criminal oh [__] he's like a high school
teacher or something reptile Smuggler
you beat up a guy that was rooting
against his team oh that's a really good
guess but he was actually a grandma
who's rooting against his team would be
a professional poker player dude yeah
she knows it I guess a power of
deduction dude someone three-bed him too
many times here's a hint it's something
he did on social media oh yeah
catfishing
not quite as bad yeah he was sending his
dick pics out it was a very it was a
very stupid thing he did it was not
clever it was all a threat he he posted
something
um he commented on something and got
arrested
he gloated about a crime he committed
it's close it's close he posted the
Kanye presidential poster
that's what it was he talked about how
he got away with something
that's pretty much the closest thing
yeah so okay so here's what happened the
um Rockdale County Police Department
their social media they posted this that
these five guys were arrested for
something she's like none of them are
even
means
that's hilarious how about me
he actually said that what else [__]
dumbass me and then this is what they
commented back
you are correct you have two warrants we
are on the way no way and they
immediately arrested him this is why
sometimes I'm like what's the point of
voting because he can vote too yeah you
know I'm like What's the 100 right when
it goes right yeah you lose your voting
right now there's a lot of people like
that all over you know that all over the
majority is actually like that yeah why
should why should we listen to majority
rule if that's the majority that's
majority right there that's what I'm
saying I don't like that at all how
about me maybe he felt bad that like man
these guys are getting the rap for what
I did this is [__] up and he was just
trying to be a Good Samaritan I thought
maybe there was like a reward if you
know more information he's like yeah I
did it look at 500 bucks what's the
reward he goes I got info
I'm [__] locked up for five years I
got all the good info I just gave that
[__] up for free yeah what a [__]
[__] how about me it'd be better if he
had the hand raised emotions and it
doesn't it doesn't like he wasn't like a
murderer or something I don't know what
he they don't say what he did in most
like crime cases I'm usually rooting for
the criminal this is the first I'm like
go get them cops
like yeah put that [__] away
from Sarge this time especially because
I really feel for all those other guys
who are like what the [__] I already
know what happened
and I'm like dude not a white guy in the
lineup dude that's probably why he was
like wait a minute this is reverse races
my guys are down too they're taking
credit for my accomplishments yeah white
guys could commit great crimes that's
what he said some serial killers that
turn themselves in because they wanted
the credit yeah yeah they hang around
the scene too long right yeah right
isn't that how you fish them out
sometimes yeah you go what a clever guy
man yeah just telling your friends like
you know you're like that guy got away
with some [__] huh he's really good at
it huh he's good he's good yep yeah
basically didn't leave a trick I guess
it said he was um his warrants were for
felony violation of probation so it's
probably nothing like super crazy but
um he definitely has the capability to
do Dumber [__] but it is a felony he
looked like he was happy to get caught
was this guy caught for just like other
things that's his mug shot
was he actually for just other things or
was he actually the culprit of that no
that that's not a this this lineup that
you're seeing with these five dudes it's
just um that's a different thing it's
something else in general and he
literally is just like how about me and
he's and they ran his name and they went
oh wait two warrants yeah you have two
warrants this isn't even his [__]
crime no not even related that's so
[__] funny do you think even like
does he follow the police department
that like is in his area why is he a
ball whoa that's actually crazy
whoever's sitting there by the way is
doing their job pretty well they
actually searched that guy like some
random [__] social media post you're
like yeah let's just run it yeah so it's
pretty good yeah that's good yeah it's
due diligence I have a suspicion that
this guy is really lonely what do you
guys think you want that gel with the
boys yeah hang out with the boys he's
hungry he's like I need some food I
think he has a mind of it even on the
the police department's social media
Facebook like I'm a fan is it Facebook
it's um it looks like Facebook yeah yeah
it does yeah yeah it's the uh Sheriff's
Department he has a mind of a
five-year-old that keeps ratting himself
out and doesn't know this is like oh
they keep catching me man this is like
that little girl who said who burned
that house down and then she turned to
the camera and went
oh my God
we know that she burned that house down
and then she's mounted the camera yeah
that's the evil in all right because of
the meme yeah it's got all the facts in
it got it in the metadata it tells the
story yeah yeah so this dude uh yep he's
in jail now and they said that like uh
even though
you know they're supposed to concentrate
on like
kind of the higher rankings
that's why I'm distracted there's a
bunch of tits there's like a bunch of
bikini ads and he keeps scrolling past
the articles
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like Sears boobs by the way Cricket
well they're mysterious boobs because
they're a little bit more covered
so they like even though they're
supposed to go after fugitives and
people like violent criminals and
whatever they made time to get this guy
because of how stupid it was
yeah I mean that's like it does make a
good story that's just one degree a way
of just literally walking into the
police station so it's just so easy does
this make this guy also on top of that
is he also a rat
by himself yeah snitches good stitches
because isn't that like the number one
yup I don't [__] like crap
I think he's a dumb [__] I hope he
changes his story before like when he
gets into jail so we don't jump his ass
like wait what how did you get caught
yeah I took I bro how about me
this guy's a mark but that's not like a
that wouldn't make him look tougher
would it because he's like come get me
that would have been tougher yeah that
would have been tough how about me it's
not really a toughness like he got left
out it's like yeah I didn't get on the
lineup picture come get me it's like
equally it's like more tough but equally
stupid though right like
if he gets caught yeah but if you say
come get me and he set up some crazy
trap Oh you mean like Spears leaning
against the door the ornaments on the
floor
you guys remember that put a pipe on
ropes the cops are like okay you guys
remember that show like world's dumbest
criminals or whatever yeah that was
great one where they were doing a
Stakeout and then the way or like they
were entrapping them and the way that
they were doing it is
um they said hey you won the lotto come
down yeah and then they even had a guy
with a [__] check and then like
everything in a whole ceremony right and
they even went there and then when the
guy came like and did the whole thing
the cops would bust out and catch him
I'm all like I love that it's so funny
that they had to even do the whole check
thing like you didn't I would take a
photo together hold it yeah you could
just [__] come in and get out of like
why did you have to do the whole thing
I'm real dude it sucks when you find out
it's funnier it sucks when you find out
you're getting arrested by the cops and
then you find out you're on world's
dumbest criminals on top of that yeah
yeah they probably had to spend that
budget they had a budget and if they
don't spend a certain amount they don't
get that much snow she had to buy the
big checks
Sports Department that hair and makeup
and if the criminal's dumb they probably
also have the emotional moment when
they're like getting arrested and
they're like wait do I still get the
money you know what I mean that's got to
be like there too you think that people
are watching the world's dumbest
criminals and there's a guy with cross
eyes who's like how about me
it's just an even lower level across
side cross-eyed Burger costume with the
money snack over the back forgot about
me guys dude those were always really
good uh episodes because it was always a
guy falling from the roof in the trailer
of those world's dumbest criminals
someone always be like trying to repel
down a like a storage room dressed like
Santa yeah I saw [__] like that guy
dressed like Santa trying to so people
see him like oh it's probably an uncle
or some [__] and then he's like Robin
houses on Christmas Eve in theory it's a
great in theory it's great like the
Grinch yeah dude Simpsons could have
saved a lot of those guys that fell for
that trick because they did an episode
where they were saying they were giving
away free boats and then Homer went and
then uh it was really just to give him
like he was like outstanding tickets or
something oh and he even said the same
thing he's like do I still get my boot
it's like dude if you just [__] watch
Simpsons
did they just watch The Simpsons but
it's the dream though is it yeah it's
the dream yeah why not that's how people
fall for scams right yeah but that's
pretty interesting that they would
correlate the data of like knowing that
most Petty criminals are kind of of
lower IQ that they would fall for
something that [__] stupid right yeah
I guess it's a shot in their head
they're probably like this will never
work but let's try it I remember one
time we went to the mall when I was a
kid as a family and it was like one of
those like cards you could win this car
so when my parents were like I'll do
[__] I put like [__] 100 entries in
and so my parents thought they won and
they had to go to this meeting and then
my dad had to get into his like best
dressed and it was like really really
crazy and I kept on pressuring them to
go and they went there and then suddenly
they got suckered into a timeshare then
they had a time oh no like a year or
something like that did the timeshare
dude they [__] get you when you get
there and my parents they don't even
speak English that well you know what I
mean so I set them up did you ever I
didn't even get a cut yeah we went to it
once and we went to a few times actually
so like we went to Cancun and we went to
Lake Tahoe and we went to yeah we went
to some cool spots oh she kind of paid
off a little bit yeah those guys are
salesmen man they are it was like a five
hour thing
I was a kid and I answered the call I
was like oh you gotta go they said we
get all Crews I didn't even get to go on
the cruise they're going to say it I'm
like where's the [__] car they didn't
take me all the time
well they're like Yay oh that's sad
[Music]